on n'y a pas de temps à prêtre le chef
conservateur andrew scheer y était hier
matin et en soirée c'était au tour de
jack meeting le chef néo-démocrate
méchant dans les services
bienvenue à brampton villes de banlieue
de toronto
une communauté qui connaît une
croissance fulgurante où les deux tiers
des résidents sont d'origine
sud-asiatique brenton c'est aussi cinq
circonscriptions électorales où les
luttes sont serrés si serré en fait
qu'on peut le constater sur le terrain
multicolores de certains électeurs
est ce que cet homme dit oui quand le
npd a demandé de poser une pancarte sur
son terrain mais il ne votera pas pour
eux courent autant il s'en voudrait si
la division du vote progressiste
profitait aux conservateurs il dit avoir
retenu la leçon de l'an passé quand il
l'a voté npd au provincial et que
d'oxford a été élu premier ministre de
l'ontario
cet étudiant vient d'avoir 18 ans il a
voté pour la première fois de sa vie par
anticipation sa priorité
s'assurer que les conservateurs ne soit
pas élu il ne propose rien pour les
familles à faibles revenus dit-il
cette femme a voté pour le frère de jack
2005 dans la circonscription aux
élections provinciales
mais elle dit qu'elle ne peut pas
appuyer le npd cette fois ci elle votera
libéral même si le scandale du visage de
justin trudeau peint en noir la offensé
c'est un vote stratégique
tout simplement
votre stratégique pour certains
questions de principes et de valeurs
pour d'autres cet homme arrivé au canada
il y a 20 ans va voter npd ne vaut rien
carrière car jack médecine propose de
s'attaquer au prix exorbitant de
l'assurance auto un enjeu local
important dans cette ville dortoir
devrait bien se qu'il ne digère pas non
plus qu'ils considèrent être un
traitement de faveur accordé par les
libéraux aux milliers de réfugiés
syriens
ils ont reçu plus d aides
gouvernementales que les immigrants
comme moi dit il renton ville clé
convoité par tous les partis communautés
déchirées à quelques jours du vote ici
philippe leblanc radio canada